GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVE IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES. IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE STATE SENATE
HAS MADE IT NECESSARY HAD MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. OUR MEMBERS ATTENDING
REMOTELY TODAY ARE SENATOR
PORTMAN TINO IN SENATOR WILK.
SENATORS ARE REPEATED AS A
REMINDER PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONES
OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL GREATLY
AID IN ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK I S. IT EVERY TIME YOU
WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED THE VIEWS
OF RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE OF
THE PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND TO AVOID CUSICK FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MUTE YOUR DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE BABY
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE NEEDING
SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR COMIC
CONNECTIONS MUTED. ONE MOMENT.
APPARENTLY I HAVE A LIMITED ONE
FULL PAGE. FROM THE NOTES SO I'M
GONNA KIND OF GO BACK AND COVER
THESE SO WE MAKE SURE THAT- THE
PUBLIC REALLY UNDERSTANDS WHAT'S
GOING ON- THE TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN A
HEARING ROOM. TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW IT WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
YOU WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I'LL ANNOUNCE IT NOW.
THE PHONE NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN THREE THREE SIX FOUR FOUR.
THREE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS EIGHT TWO SIX. EIGHT FOUR TWO
EIGHT. FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW- THE TELECONFERENCES TO
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
IN OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. IT'S
THE ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
COULD BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE I
NEEDED AND YOU ARE NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. ALL
RIGHT. WE HAVE TWO BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. FOR WE HEAR
PRESENTATIONS ON THE BILL LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. DOT YOUR DAUGHTER
HERE NIELSEN NO SENSE HERE ALAN
. ALAN HERE ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA
HERE BECKER GORGEOUS VIRTUS PRO
PRESIDENT BRADFORD. BRADFORD
HERE GLASER LATER HERE WEST SO.
JONES JONES HERE CAN LONGER
CAMERA HERE MELENDEZ MELENDEZ
HERE POURED INTO NOW. HERE
ACCORDING TO YOU KNOW HEAR RUBIO
. RUBIO PRESIDENT WILL. GERMANY
HAVE A POOR. THANK YOU. WE WILL
BEGIN WITH OUR CONSECUTIVE WHICH
INCLUDES FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE SP
FOUR FORTY CAN I HAVE A MOTION
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR GLAZER-
MEMBERS REMINDER TO PLEASE WAIT
UNTIL YOUR MIKE IS TURNED ON IT
IS SPEAK DIRECTLY INTO THE BIKE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HE AMBER WE NEED A MICROPHONE
THERE. NOW RIGHT NOW. OKAY
MEMBERS THIS IS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR DONNA HI DONNA HI
NIELSEN. NIELSEN HI ALAN.
BALENTINE ARCHULETA ARCHULETA HI
BECKER FORGES BORDERS HI
BRADFORD. BRADFORD HI GLAZER
PLEASE R. I. WESO. JONES JONES
HI KEN LONGER. CAN LIKE OR I
MILLAND AS MELENDEZ ARE POURED
INTO YOU KNOW. FLORENTINO SP
FOUR FORTY HI ACCORDING TO YOU
KNOW HI RUBIO. RUBIO HI WELCOME. RUBIO THAT'S WHAT THAT IS YEAH
HE'S ON THE OTHER. TWELVE ZERO
TERM YEAH WE ARE FOUR ZERO ON
CALL. IT'S TWELVE ZERO THE BILLS
ON CALL. NOW- LET'S HEAR FROM
OUR ONLY AUTHOR TODAY. WELCOME
SENATOR ALLEN YOU MAY PRESENT SB
SIX TWENTY. WELL THANK YOU AND
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. I LET ME START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
REFLECTED ANALYSIS I ALSO WANT
TO THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR YOUR
DEDICATED WORK ON THIS ISSUE
OVER THE LAST YEAR- FOLKS I WILL
REMEMBER THAT WE'VE HAD THIS
BILL IN PRINT FOR. ASSISTANCE
THE BEGINNING OF LAST YEAR WE
HAD A GREAT- SESSION ON THIS-
HEARING OVER THE INTERIM. YOU
KNOW ONE SILVER LINING OF THIS
TERRIBLE PANDEMIC HAS BEEN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SOME CREATIVE
POLICY IDEA SPURRED BY THE NEED
TO ADJUST TO LIFE. UNDER
COVERAGE RESTRICTIONS. AT TEN
STATES AND THE DISTRICT OF
COLUMBIA ALLOW JUST DIRECT TO
CONSUMER SHIPPING FOR FEAR AND
DISTILLED SPIRITS. DURING THE
COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC
ADDITIONAL STATES ALLOWED
ALCOHOL PRODUCERS TO SHIP.
DIRECTLY TO CONSUMERS AS A
TEMPORARY ECONOMIC RELIEF
MEASURE. IN MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY GOVERNOR NEWSOM DIRECTED
A DIFFERENT ALCOHOL BEVERAGE
CONTROL TO ALLOW DIRECT TO
CONSUMER SHIPPING OF DISTILLED
SPIRITS THIS IS ONE OF SEVERAL
POLICIES PUT IN PLACE TO RESPOND
TO CONSUMER DEMAND. IN THE
SOCIALLY DISTANT ECONOMY AND IT
WAS EXTENDED THROUGH THE END OF
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY TWO JUST
BEFORE. THE NEW YEAR. THEY HAD
THE STATE NOT INTERVENED. I AM
ALLOWED FOR THE TEMPORARY
ABILITY FOR DIRECT TO CONSUMER
SHIPPING OF DISTILLED SPIRITS
MANY LOCAL DISTILLERIES MAY HAVE
BEEN FORCED TO SHUT DOWN. EMILY
AND WE ALL HAVE THESE SMALL
DISTILLERIES IN OUR DISTRICTS.
WITH THIS BILL WE GOT AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT THESE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS BY CREATING
A BETTER SYSTEM ALL WHILE
INCREASING ACCESS CONVENIENCE
AND SAFETY FOR CONSUME FOR
CUSTOMERS. ALREADY UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW BOTH IN STATE AND
OUT OF STATE WINE GROWERS ARE
AUTHORIZED TO SELL AND SHIP WINE
DIRECTLY TO CONSUMERS. WE'VE
SEEN THE DIRECT TO CONSUMER
MODEL WORK EFFECTIVELY IN THE
WINE MARKET OTHER STATES IN
CALIFORNIA THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC AND WE KNOW IT'S WHAT.
CONSUMERS WANT. I SHOULD MENTION
I'M WORKING WITH LABOR WITH THE
FOLKS OUR FRIENDS FROM THE
TEAMSTERS TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS COME TO A COMPROMISE
JUST HAD A GREAT MEETING WITH
THEM YESTERDAY- ULTIMATELY THIS
IS ABOUT. ENSURING THAT THE BILL
SUPPORTS CONSUMER ACCESS GROWING
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES AND JOBS
ACROSS THE STATE. HERE WITH ME
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF OUR
QUESTS WALKER THE CEO OF DISCUS
ALEX. CONNOR FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ARTISANAL DISTILLERS GUILD AND
LORI AJAX. EXACTLY DIRECTOR OF
THE CRAFT BREWERS ASSOCIATION.
THE SO IF YOU WANT WE COULD
START WITH MR SAGER PERHAPS.
THIS IS ONE ARE YOU THERE. YES
HI CHAIRMAN DATIN THANK YOU OUR
INSPECTION READY READY FOR ME TO
TESTIFY WE SURE ARE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY THANK YOU SIR I
CHAIRMAN DIED IN MEMBERS I AM
CHRIS LONGER PRESIDENT AND CEO
OF THE DISTILLED SPIRITS COUNCIL
OF THE UNITED STATES. WHILE ALSO
WORKING IN CONCERT ON F. B. SIX
TWENTY WITH THE AMERICAN CRAFT
SPIRITS ASSOCIATION AMERICAN
DISTILLING INSTITUTE THE
CALIFORNIA OR TESTIMONIAL IN
FULL SUPPORT OF SB SIX ONE. IN
ORDER FOR ENERGY'S SB TEXT.
WHICH WOULD PREVENT DIRECT TO
CONSUMER SHEPHERD OF SPIRITUAL
COMMONLY KNOWN AS BTC. ANOTHER
WAY TO DESCRIBE IT IN THE STORY
THE DOORBELL SHELTON. FOR THE
RECORD GIVES GETS FULLY SUPPORTS
OUR WHOLESALE AND RETAIL
PARTNERS. THEY ARE THE
CORNERSTONES OF RESPONSIBLE IN A
FLOURISHING BEVERAGE ALCOHOL
MARKET WE DO BELIEVE HOWEVER THE
THREE TIER SYSTEM SHOULD
MODERNIZED TO REFLECT THE NEW
MARKET MARKET PLACE. IN THE
STORY THE DOORBELL SHOP AND NO
DTC BALL COMPLEMENT THE
CREATURES TOOK THEM. UP TO ALL
CONSUMER DEMAND IN CREATE
CONSUMER POLL ALTERNATELY.
HOPING THE THREE CHEERS FOR. THE
MAJORITY DISK NUMBERS FULLY THE
DRUG CONCERNED SHEPHERD. BY THE
LICENSEE. BY THE ALPHA TOBACCO
TAX AND TRADE BUREAU. ANY
LEGISLATION THAT SHOULD REFLECT
- CERTAINLY SHOULD LOOK LIKE
DIFFICULT CORRECTABLE HE HAD
PRIVILEGE PREVIOUSLY SHARED WITH
THE COMMITTEE INCLUDING A
RESPONSIBLE BODY ELECTRIC
SHIPPING ONE. THESE PRINCIPLES
WILL HELP ENSURE THAT ANY
DIRECTOR CONSUMER SHIPPING
LEGISLATION DID NOT LEAD TO
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. THAT
COMPROMISE THE INTEGRITY OF
RESPONSIBLE DISTRIBUTION OF
BEVERAGE ALCOHOL THERE ARE THREE
POINTS. WORK DID- DETAIL. IF THE
DOOR SHIP AND SO TO THE LAW RAMP
SMALL PRODUCE THAT WITH
ESTABLISHED WHOLESALERS WITH
MORE THAN TWO. THREE HUNDRED
CRAFT DISTILLERS ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES. IN MORE THAN
FIFTEEN THOUSAND SPIRITS
PRODUCTS ARE CRITICAL SAILORS IN
RETAILERS CAN'T MOST POSSIBLY
THAT ARE AVAILABLE IN THE
MARKETPLACE. ESPECIALLY THOSE
ARE BETTER SMALL. WORLD REGIONAL
INTERESTS. D. C. PROVIDED BY FOR
SOME DE. TO HELP SHOWCASE A
BRAND FOLLOWING THAT IT'S
CRITICAL TO THE PRODUCER TO BE
ABLE MAKE THE ECONOMIC CASE FOR
BROADER DISTRIBUTION TO THE
WHOLESALE PARTNERSHIP. THIS
HELPS CREATE CONSUMER PULL IN
CONSUMER DEMAND. ZERO DO TO
CONSUMER CONCERT BEEN ADDITIONAL
AVENUES FOR CONSUMER INTERACTION
FROM LARGER PRODUCERS LOOKING TO
PROVIDE THEIR OPINIONS WITH
PRODUCTS NOT GEOGRAPHICALLY
AVAILABLE. ITEMS LIMITED TO
DISTILLERY ONLY BOTTLINGS FOR
UNIQUE SUBSCRIPTION OFFERING.
SIMILAR TO WINE CLUB. WE DO NOT
ANTICIPATE CONSUMERS ORDER
PRODUCT ONLINE THAT IS AVAILABLE
AFTER GREAT LOCAL RETAILERS YOU
HAVE A HIGH COST OF SHIP IN A
LECTURE TIME ACQUIRED THROUGH
DELIBERATE SPIRITS DIRECTOR
CONSUMER SHOPPING IS A NATURALLY
SELF LIMITING- WITH CONSUMERS
ONLY WILLING TO PAY THE EXTRA
COSTS WITH PRODUCT WHATEVER
REASON. ARE NOT AVAILABLE IN THE
LOCAL MARKET THIS WILL ALLOW
CONSUMERS FROM CONTRACT- OTHER
STATES THE PURCHASE CALIFORNIA
CRAFT BEER BRAND IN THIS IS AN
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITY FOR THESE. TWO
AFFECTS SMALL BUSINESSES. MY DAY
COMES WERE AND HE CONVENIENCE
WHAT TO PURCHASING THEIR
FAVORITE PRODUCTS INCLUDING
DISTILLED. SPIRITS HOW DO WE
KNOW CONSUMERS ARE DEMANDING
GREATER ACCESS DISCUSS WITH
TENDAI W. SOLD FOR MORE THAN TWO
THOUSAND AMERICANS AT THIS PAST
YEAR. OKAY CONFORM NATIONALLY
73% OF ALL HOUSEHOLDS SHOP
ONLINE THE BUSH. 80% OF
CONSUMERS NATIONWIDE BELIEVE THE
SELLER SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO DROP
SHIP THEIR PRODUCTS THE LEGAL
AGE CONSUMERS THAN ANY STATE. IN
SEVENTY SIX HELLO- PERSONALLY
CALIFORNIANS AGREED THAT-
DISTILLERY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
SHOW UP- AND DISTILLED SPIRITS
DIRECTLY FROM THE DISTILLERY. IN
SHOULD HAVE THE SAME PRIVILEGES
THOSE WINERIES TO SHIP DIRECTLY
AS WELL THIS IS A LONG WORD
INDUSTRIES WATER INTO THE HOLE
FOR JUST A MOMENT. I'M SORRY I
DO THIS I'M SORRY TO DO THIS TO
YOU BUT I. YEAH WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE ALLOCATING SIX MINUTES I
KNOW THAT THESE RULES WERE PUT
OUT TO EVERYBODY HAD A TIME. FOR
IN TOTAL FOR- UP TO FOUR
WITNESSES I BELIEVE IT'S ON EACH
SIDE SO YOU'RE YOU'RE AT THREE
MINUTES AND THIRTY SECONDS.
YOU'RE KINDA EATEN IN THE OTHER
TO. TIME BUT I DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOU GUYS HAVE- SCHEDULE FOR
YOURSELF SO WITH THAT ADMONITION
PLEASE PROCEED. OKAY WOULD YOU
LIKE ME TO COME LIVE IN. THEM-
OKAY YOU GOT IT WELL OBVIOUSLY I
THINK EVERYBODY IS WHERE
CALIFORNIA WINERIESCAN BE
JOINED- ENJOYED DIRECTOR
CONSUMER SHOPPING CENTER IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX AND IT'S
BEEN A GREAT SUCCESS. IT WAS A
LOT OF DATA AVAILABLE THAT THIS
HAPPENED BECAUSE- OBLONG IN A
MATTER OF FACT FOR EXAMPLE IN
TWO THOUSAND FIVE RETAIL
EMPLOYEES THE LIQUOR STORES IN
CALIFORNIA INCREASED MORE THAN
30% EMPLOYMENT IN THE WINE AND
SPIRITS WHOLESALERS SEGMENT HAS
GROWN FROM FIFTY THOUSAND IN TWO
THOUSAND ONE TO EIGHTY. DOLLARS
MARK. THANK YOU- NEXT WEEK- WILL
BE ALLAH VILLA KANA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ARTISANS GUILD.
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU JERRY
DODD SENATOR ALAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AT MY NAME IS ALEX WILL
COME OUT EVERY FIVE DISTILLERIES
AFTER A BUS ON CALIFORNIA'S
CENTRAL COAST I'M REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ARTISANAL
DISTILLERS GUILD MADE UP OF OVER
A HUNDRED FIFTY CRAFT DISTILLERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS CALIFORNIA JUST
IN GREECE HAVE BEEN ALLOWED IN
THE PROVEN THAT THEY CAN SAFELY
SHIP SPIRIT USING COMMON
CARRIERS LIKE UPS THAT ACTS ARE
REQUIRING ID CHECK IN AT ADULT
SIGNATURE VERIFICATIONS
CURRENTLY SMALL DISTILLERY TO
SHIP BETEEN TWENTY AND 30% OF
THEIR TOTAL SALES DIRECT TO
CONSUMER THIS IS A SUBSTANTIAL
REVENUE SOURCE FOR CRAFTERS
DEALERS THAT WE CANNOT AFFORD TO
LOSE. VTP LEGISLATION FOR
WINERIES CREATED A FINANCIAL
BURDEN FOR THIS ALL STAKEHOLDERS
GROWING INDUSTRY FROM SEVEN
HUNDRED WINERIES TO FOUR
THOUSAND INCREASING SALES FROM
FIVE BILLION TO FORTY BILLION HE
WILL DO THE SAME FOR
DISTILLERIES THAT THANK YOU
KEITH BE AN ISSUE WHERE SOMEONE
LOSES OR OTHERS GAME WE SHOULD
LOOK AS THOUGH THE WINE INDUSTRY
AND SEE THAT IT IS REALLY A WIN
WIN PROPOSITION. WHOLESALERS AND
RETAILERS BENEFIT CALIFORNIA
DISTILLERS WOULD LOVE TO PARTNER
WITH DISTRIBUTORS NIKITA
PRODUCTS ON STORE SHELVES AND IN
RESTAURANTS THAT NEED TO
INCREASE BRAND RECOGNITION
BEFORE DISTRIBUTORS RETAILERS.
IMPROPERLY NO ONE PROFITS THE
PRODUCT YOU SELL. DIRECT CONCERN
SHIPPING IT TO. ON RAP SMALLS.
NAILING A GROSS WE CAN DO TO. IN
THE THREE D. SYSTEM. THE LABOR
BENEFIT. DIRECT TO CONSUMERS IS
THE KEY ALLY THAT WILL
DISTILLERIES TO GROW CREATING
NEW JOBS. A DISTILLERY'S GROW
THEY SECURE DISTRIBUTION
CREATING NEW JOBS FOR
DISTRIBUTORS AND RETAILERS
SHIPPING MORE MEANS MORE JOBS
FOR YOU PS THAT ACTION
MANUFACTURERS. THE CONSUMER
BENEFITS. DIRECT TO CONSUMER
SHIPPING BENEFITS THE CONSUMER
BY PROVIDING A MISTAKE YOU
CANNOT BUILD A CONVENIENCE AND
CHOICE. AND THEN I GUESS YOU'RE
MAD AND PERMANENTLY CHANGED
CONSUMER BEHAVIOUR CEMENTING
ONLINE SHOPPING AT THE DOMINANT
MEANS PURCHASING. THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SHIPPING LOG
BETWEEN WINE AND SPIRITS.
CALIFORNIA BENEFIT CALIFORNIA
WILL BENEFIT FROM INCREASED JOBS
AND TAX REVENUE. EXCISE TAXES
THREE DOLLARS AND THIRTY CENTS A
GALLON SIXTEEN AND A HALF TIMES
HIGHER. THAN THE TWENTY CENTS A
GALLON PER LINE. I ASK YOU TO
FOLLOW THE ROAD MAP OF THE WINE
INDUSTRY HAS ALREADY PROVIDED
AND SUPPORT SB SIX TWENTY MAKING
DIRECT CONSUMER SHIPPING. BY
SPIRITS PRODUCERS PERMANENT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU A
MISSILE CONNOR NOW WE HAVE LORI
AJAX WITH THE CALIFORNIA CRAFT
BREWERS ASSOCIATION. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN DIED IN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LORI AJAX LET ME EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA CRAFT
BREWERS ASSOCIATION. CALIFORNIA
BREWERIES HAVE ALWAYS HAD THE
ABILITY TO SELL BEER THEY
PRODUCE DIRECTLY TO CONSUMERS
WHETHER APPLE CAP ROOM OR
THROUGH DIRECT TO CONSUMER
SHIPPING LIKE THE WALKING ON THE
STREET. HOWEVER STATE LOTTERY IN
ST BREWERY DIFFERENT THAN OUT OF
STATE BREWERY. IN EQUITY IN
TREATMENT BECAUSE OF THE
SIGNIFICANT LEGAL RISK THE
CALIFORNIA CRAFT BEER INDUSTRY
AND PPP EIGHT WEEKS TO HARMONIZE
THE STATE LAW WITH FEDERAL LAW
TO PROTECT OUR DUTY AND
PRIVILEGE. DIRECT TO CONSUMERS
OF FORTY PART OF THE BREWERY'S
OVERALL BUSINESS BEING FIFTEEN
DIRECT TO CONSUMER PRIVILEGE FOR
CRAFT BREWERIES HAS ALWAYS BEEN
ESSENTIAL IN THE PROMOTION OF
NEW PRODUCTS. MAINTAINING AND
GROWING SALES. BOTH IN STATE AND
OUT OF DATE. ACCORDING TO YOUR
THEM AND OF CRAFT BEER IN. CLUB
MOST READ. COVERED WITH MAY.
ENCLOSURE TO HIGHLIGHT HOW
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THESE
PRIVILEGES ARE KEY TO CONTINUE
TO HELP THE INDUSTRY. THE SIX
TWENTY PROVIDE THEIR DIRECT TO
CONSUMER PRIVILEGES WITH THE
SAME PROTECTIONS AS THE WINE
INDUSTRY RECEIVED FROM THE
LEGISLATURE IN TWO THOUSAND
FIVE. THE FINANCIAL WELL BEING
AND CONTINUED GROWTH THE
CALIFORNIA CRAFT BREWERY AND A
LOCAL JOB SEEKER PROVIDE ARE YOU
WITH YOUR IPHONE UNDER THE OKAY
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY THIS MORNING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SO- THAT WAS JUST SO
EVERYBODY KNOWS I WAS ABOUT
EIGHT MINUTES I'M GONNA MAKE
SURE THAT THE OPPOSITION AND
THEIR- WITNESSES- I GET THE
TIME- THAT THEY WOULD LIKE UP TO
EIGHT MINUTES. OUT SO LET'S
CONTINUE WITH ANY WITNESSES HERE
IN THE CHAMBER. WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE CHAMBER I SEE
NONE THANK YOU WILL MOVE ON TO
THE WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORDERS.
LADIES GENTLEMEN ON THE PHONE
LINES IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY- PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY THE ZERO ON A. T. T.
OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOUR LIFE
NUMBER OFFLINE AND PLACE YOU
BACK IN THE QUEUE SO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
MOMENT AS PARTICIPANTS QUEUE UP. WE HAVE A- NUMBER OF
PARTICIPANTS- QUEUING UP. ON MR
SCHERER IS THIS JUST FOR SUPPORT
FOR- SB SIX TWENTY AT THE TIME.
THAT'S CORRECT THIS IS JUST IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL- MODERATOR
IF YOU.COULD PLEASE GIVE ME THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT- Q.
THERE'S A LOT LET ME OKAY WE'RE
MAXED OUT WELL OVER. YEAH YOU'RE
WAY WAY MAX OUT I CAN GUARANTEE
THAT- LET'S GET STARTED TODAY
WITH- ABSOLUTELY LIKE SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF BOTH MILLER ON
BEHALF OF U. P. S. IN SUPPORT
THAT THAT'LL BE SIX TWENTY S.
FOR MY BOOK. THANK YOU. WHY
TWENTY NINE YOU ARE A. HI MR
HERE MEMBERS MY NAME IS STANDING
HERE AND I AM A SOLE GRAPHIC R.
ET I'M ALSO A PROUD MEMBER URGES
NO VOTE ON IT BETWEEN SIX POINT
. WE GO NINE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIRTY ONE YOUR OPERATION
. PICTURE NUMBERS NINETY JAMIE
DIAMOND AND TELEGRAPH AT THE
OTHER END GLAZERS WANT- I'M ALSO
PROUD TEAMSTER MEMBER CARD
YOU'RE NO PROBLEM AT LEAST
TWENTY ALL RIGHT OPERATOR PLEASE
STOP HERE I MADE IT. MAKE A PLEA
TO THE PEOPLE THAT ARE OUT THERE
THEY'RE LISTENING ONLINE WE ARE
ASKING FOR SUPPORT. OF SB SIX
TWENTY NOW IF YOU WANT TO OPPOSE
THEY'LL BE PLENTY OF TIME FOR
YOU TO GET ON. INVOICE YOUR YOUR
OPPOSITION. TO THIS TWO SB SIX
TWENTY SO ONLY THOSE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL STAY ON THE LINE
EVERYBODY ELSE PLEASE GET OFF.
OPERATOR PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU AND AS HE MATURES SAID
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AGAIN TO
TAKE YOURSELF OUT OF THE QUEUE
THAT MISTAKE YOU OUT AND YOU CAN
QUEUE UP AGAIN WHEN. HE'S READY
FOR OPPOSITION AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE TWENTY SIX YOUR OPEN. NINE
TWENTY SIX. ONE MORE TRY LIKE
TWENTY SIX. HELLO THIS IS I'M
STEPHEN HARRISON CEO OF THE
NATION I IN THE PORT OF SB SIX
TWENTY AND THE COMMON SENSE
APPROACH TO THE BASEMENT FUNK
WILL DIRECT TO CONSUMER SALES OF
SPIRITS AND BEER. WE ARE A
COMPANY THAT IS MANAGED
COMPLIANCE. TO DIRECT A LINE. M.
HUNDRED THANK YOU SOMETHING. AND
MORE THAN TWO AND A HALF
THOUSAND PRODUCED WITH ACROSS
THE COUNTRY FOR THE FIFTEEN YEAR
. BEING A SHIP ALONG WITH OTHER
COMPLIANT SOFTWARE PROVIDED THAT
THE NAPLES MANY HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DTC TRANSACTIONS
OVER THE- TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE
AND TAX TRANSACTION. THE MAILBOX
COMPLEX HOWEVER TECHNOLOGY
EXISTS TODAY TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THE PRE PURCHASE AND ON
DELIVERY AGE VERIFICATION
COLLECTION AND REPORTING
IMPACTED. AND TRACEABILITY
SHIPMENTS. AND BIN TERE AT
TESTED BY THEIR DINGLE. AND US
UNDER A BUYERS YOU FELT A
VERIFICATION PRE IT. FAILED VERY
OF AGE UPON DELIVERY. AS WELL AS
HAVE TO CHALLENGE VOLUME LIMIT
THEM EFFECTIVE STATE RESISTANCE
YOU COLLIDE HAVE INSURED THAT WE
ENACT QUIETLY PASSED WITH GREAT
SUCCESS EACH TIME. I MEAN
CONNECT CONSUMERS DIRECTLY WITH
PRODUCERS WHILE MAINTAINING WILL
REGULATE THE FLAME OPERATOR WE
HAVE THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WE'RE ASKING JUST FOR SUPPORT.
THE NAME OF THE- AND SOME. YES
WHY NOT THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GUYS MY NAME'S MICHAEL
BARBER I WON I RUN A SMALL
WINERY AND A SMALL DISTILLERY
AND I'M AMAZED AT THE RIGHT THE
WINERIES HAVE THE CRAFT
DISTILLERS DOWN I SUPPORT THIS
BILL IT MAKES NO SENSE FOR IT
NOT TO BE SUPPORTED. THANK YOU.
NINE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE THIRTY FIVE YOUR OPEN.
ONE MORE TRY LINE THIRTY FIVE.
MOVING ALONG WE'LL GO TO LINE
THIRTY OR EXCUSE ME LIKE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE FORTY YOU
ARE OPEN. FORTY MOVE ALL RIGHT
YOUR LIFE FORTY THANK YOU LINE
FORTY SIX PLEASE CALL AT. GERMAN
JAMES GREEN BOND- WITH VENTURA
WE'RE IN VENTURA CALIFORNIA AND
I SUPPORT THAT B. SIX TWENTY.
THANK YOU LINE THIRTY FIVE. ONE
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MOVING ALONG LINE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THERE MY NAME IS HENRY CHARMING
I'M ONE OF THE FOUNDERS OF
VENTURE COMPANY HERE IN VENTURA
CALIFORNIA AND I WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT YEAH AND HE TAKES
TWENTY. THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
THIRTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. R.
EIGHT LINE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS BRIAN KERR
WITH ROTTEN HAMMER SO TELL ME
DOWN THE STAIRS BUT CALIFORNIA
AND I WORK AT TI SIX TWENTY
THANK YOU. THE LINE SIXTY NINE
YOU ARE OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
JACQUELINE HE'S AND I'M ROUTING
HAMMER SLOW DOWN. IN DECEMBER
THE BANK OF CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT SB SIX. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU WINDS ARE
EXPECTED SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SIX YOU ARE OPEN. GOING ALONG
WITH THE LINE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KETAN
KENYA I'M WITH SHELTER
DISTILLING IN MAMMOTH LAKES
CALIFORNIA. NINE THE COURT HE
TALKING. THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
CHARLIE MANSKE FROM ROTTEN
HAMMERS CLOSE THOUGH AND THEN
THERE'S THE BIT FROM CALIFORNIA
AND I SUPPORT AT SIX TWENTY.
THANK YOU. NINE EIGHTY FIVE YOU
ARE OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS STEVE AUTRY I OWN A TREE
SELLERS IN SAN LUIS OBISPO
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT SB. SIX
TWENTY. ONE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I THINK THEY TOOK
THEM- LINE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M STEVE AUTRY
FROM AUTRY SELLERS IN SAN LUIS
OBISPO CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT SB
SIX TWENTY. NINE EIGHTY NINE
YOUR OPEN. NINE EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO IT'S
GOING TO OPEN. MICHAEL BASH FROM
TEN THIRTY TO ELEVEN AM
WEINSTEIN DISTILLERY IN PASO
ROBLES CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT
SIX TWENTY. THANK YOU THE FINAL
REMINDER- EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE HAVE
JUST A COUPLE MORE QUEUING UP
MISTER CHAIR ONE MOMENT. IN LINE
. AT MOMENT. I THANK YOU. WHY
NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS PATRICK BROOKS
FROM TEN FIFTY DISTILLERY IN
PAST ROBLES CALIFORNIA AND I'M
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU MOVING ALONG WE'LL GO
TO LINE ONE HUNDRED AND THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CAL
LIGHT COMPANY IMPASSABLE
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB SIX TWENTY. AN ACTUAL
LINE ONE HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD
. I HAVE I HAVE A QUESTION MIGHT
. MY NAME IS TARA JASPER I AM
THE FOUNDER AND HEAD DISTILLER
FIRST STEPS ON IT IN THE NUMBER
COUNTY CALIFORNIA- SIX TWENTY
WOULD GET TO MAKE OR BREAK MY
BUSINESS IT IS I CANNOT SUPPORT
IT MORE STRONGLY AT IT WOULD BE
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING FOR MY
BUSINESS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU ALL THE LINE NINETY
YOU ARE OPEN ON. HI THIS IS MAX
FROM ROD HAMMER ROTTEN HAMMERS
CLOSE DEALS AND I AM IN SUPPORT
OF BILL SB SIX POINT. WHY TWENTY
EIGHT EUROPE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HOW MANY GAVIN FULLER T. I'M
WITH SHELTER DISTILLING IN
MAMMOTH LAKES CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT SB SIX TWENTY. AND
MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
THE SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS. IN HERE FROM
ANY OPPOSITION- WE DO HAVE EIGHT
MINUTES ALLOCATED FOR THE FOUR
SPEAKERS THAT ARE HERE. I'M
GONNA BREAK THAT DOWN INTO TWO
MINUTES SLOTS UNLESS THE FIRST
PERSON TELLS ME THAT YOU ALREADY
HAVE HOW THAT ALL BROKEN DOWN
HOW YOU GUYS WANT TO DO IT. BUT
WE'LL START THERE WE'LL BEGIN
WITH MARLON MANSOOR PRESIDENT
THE NEIGHBORHOOD MARKET
ASSOCIATION. I BELIEVE HE'S ON
THE COASTLINE. MR MANSOOR. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN DIED IN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE. MY NAME IS
MARLIN OR ME INSURE I MEAN THE
PRESIDENT THE NEIGHBORHOOD
MARKET ASSOCIATION. NONPROFIT
TRADE ASSOCIATION. CONSISTING OF
OVER SIX HUNDRED FIFTY.
INDEPENDENT FAMILY OWNED
BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
. WE HAVE MANY CONCERNS AT FIFTY
SIX TWENTY. ONE THE IMPACT ON
FAMILY OWNED BUSINESSES IN THEIR
FAMILY. EVERY FILLED BY AN OUT
OF STATE DISTILLER. THE ONE
TAKEN AWAY FROM A CALIFORNIA
RETAILER. IN TURN BE AFFECTED
THIS BILL WILL GREATLY DAMAGE
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
INEFFECTUAL FLOW DOWN AND
GREATLY IMPACT ALL FACETS OF THE
THREE TIER SYSTEM. EVERYTHING
POPPED IN PLACE FOR A HUNDRED
YEARS. WELL BUSINESS OWNERS AND
RETAILERS HAVE BECOME A PART OF
THE FABRIC OF THEIR COMMUNITIES
- NOT ONLY JOB CREATORS. ENGINE
DRIVERS THEY'RE ACTIVE IN THEIR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS THANKS FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. WHAT THIS LAW DOES.
HERE'S AT THE BENEFIT OF OUT OF
STATE. LARGE CORPORATIONS. SMALL
BUSINESSES HAVE A COMMITTED TO
COMPLAIN. HELP ORGANIZE EBC LI
CRANING. HELP HAVE MEETINGS WITH
ABC LEADERSHIP. TO ENSURE THAT
THEIR PLEASE. THE SECOND THEY'RE
ABIDING BY THE RULES. ARTISTRY
DISTRIBUTORS IN CONGLOMERATES
ARE NOT GOING TO DO THAT ANY
PENALTIES THAT THEY FACE WILL BE
A DROP IN THE BUCKET NOT ONLY
HAVE A DIMINISHED IMPACT. ON
THEIR ACTIONS. THIS BILL WILL
CREATE AN AVALANCHE OF ISSUES
WITH REGARD TO UNDERAGE ACCESS
OF ALCOHOL BECAUSE THIS BODY
HAVE TO RESOLVE COMPLAINTS
ISSUES AND CREATE A COMPLEX
REGULATORY SKI PLEASE CLOSE THIS
MONSTER THANK. SOME PROTECT
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES ARE
BUSINESSES. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU MR MONTHS OR NOW WILL
MOVE TO MATT BROAD- ROAD SKEWS
ME ABI HALF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL
. MR BROKE IF YOU'RE SHARING
MEMORIES CAN YOU HEAR ME OK
GREAT GO AHEAD. GREAT MAP RIGHT
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS WE ARE AND RESPECTFUL
BUT STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB SIX
TWENTY BY SENATOR ALAN. ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THE TEAMSTERS
REPRESENT THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS
IN THE WHOLESALE DISTRIBUTION
INDUSTRY INCLUDING THOSE IN
WAREHOUSING DIRECT SALES
CUSTOMER SERVICE DELIVERY AND
MORE THESE ARE CAREER SUSTAINING
JOB IN THE LEGAL PART MANAGEMENT
PARTNERSHIP IN THE INDUSTRY IN
THE SHINING EXAMPLE OF HOW IT
SHOULD WORK. IN FACT IT'S ONE OF
THE FEW INDUSTRIES. WITH NEAR
COMPLETE UNION DENSITY WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH OUR EMPLOYERS TO
FACILITATE WORKER SAFETY AS WELL
THE SAME RELIABLE DISTRIBUTION
OF ALCOHOL THE LOCAL RESTAURANTS
GROCERY STORE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD MARKETS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA- BUSINESSES THAT ARE
ADDED MY CO PRESENTER SAID THE
FABRIC OF OUR COMMUNITY. PUT
SIMPLY ASK ME SIX TWENTY AN
EXISTENTIAL THREAT THE WORK OUR
MEMBERS DO YOU THE PROVERBIAL
WOLF IN SHEEP'S CLOTHING AND ONE
THAT SEEKS TO DISMANTLE AND YOU
REGULATE THE FREE CARE CENTER.
DOWN IN FAVOR OF DIRECT TO
CONSUMER MODEL. I KNOW THAT'S
WHY BOTH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION UFCW. ARE JOINING US
IN OPPOSITION. OPPONENTS OF THE
BILL EVEN ASKED ME TO TWENTY
AFTER OFF. TO BRING CRACK
PRODUCTS TO MARKET. BUT THEY
STILL BUILD ZERO TO. BETWEEN
CORE OUT OF THE SELLERS AND YOU
LOCAL DISTILLERS THAT MAY SMELL
CELL MOL BIOL YOU. PRICED HIGH
PRICE ITEMS UNAVAILABLE ON THE
SHELF. THANK Y. INTO LAST WEEK
THE BILL HAD ZERO RESTRICTION
ON. ON HOW MUCH ALCOHOL CAN BE
SHIPPED DIRECTLY TO CONSUMERS.
WITH RETHINKING MANY AMANDA
SUBRATA. GOOGLE ANY PLEASE CLOSE
. SUREHI I WOULD YOU SAY THAT
WE DON'T THAT THE COMMITTEE.
SERIOUSLY TACKLE THE THREAT THE
BILL PRESENTER MEMBERS WORKS OUR
WORK AND WE ARE OPEN TO A NARROW
EXCEPTION FOR TRUE CRAFT
DISTILLERS. SO THEY CAN GROW
THEIR BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU THANKS WAS BROAD NEXT
IS JOE LYING ON BEHALF OF
REPUBLIC NATIONAL DISTRIBUTING.
CALIFORNIA THE FLYING. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF HOPEFULLY YOU CAN
HEAR ME OKAY. LOG COLOR. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE THE
FAIRNESS THAN ALLOCATION OF
TIME- AS STATED I REPRESENT-
REPUBLIC. NATIONAL DISTRIBUTING
FORMALLY YOUNG'S MARKET COMPANY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA FOUR HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE YEARS WE'VE MADE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS OPEN
FACILITIES THAN JOBS OVER THAT
PERIOD OF TIME AND IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE TEAMSTERS
UNION THAT JUST TESTIFIED. I
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS. THE REAL QUESTION POSED
BY THE BILL HASN'T BEEN FULLY
DISCUSS. THE QUESTION IS THIS
BILL INTENDED TO HELP SMALL
CRAFT DISTILLERS. FOR THAT
INTENDED TO HELP LARGE CORPORATE
. DISTILLERS OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT THE QUESTION
PRESENTED BY THIS BILL- I WOULD
TELL YOU THAT WE WOULD SUPPORT
MOST OF THE COMMENTS MADE BY THE
CRAFT DISTILLERS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THEY IN FACT WE ARE
SENSITIVE TO THEIR CONCERNS THEY
WERE IMPACTED BY KOGAN AND WE
WANT TO HELP THEM. UNFORTUNATELY
THE BILL IN HELPING THEM ALSO
HELP. LARGE OUT OF STATE THE
SOLAR CORPORATIONS WITH
SIGNIFICANT MARKETING POWER AND
THAT. SOMETHING THAT WE JUST
CAN'T SUPPORT. WE ARE SUPPORTIVE
OF HELPING CRAFT DISTILLERS AND
CREATING A VOLUME LIMITATION THE
BALL OUT OF. BEEN CRAVING THAT
IN OVERTIME SO THAT THE INDUSTRY
IS ITSELF. AND GRAPPLE WITH THIS
CHANGE AND HAVE IT HAPPEN
SEAMLESSLY AND SMOKE. HOWEVER
THIS BILL DOESN'T DO THAT. IN
THE LAST THING I WOULD CLOSE
WITHIN THE CONCEPT THAT
CONSUMERS NEED ADDITIONAL CHOICE
. CONSUMERS HAVE THAT CHOICE
RIGHT NOW NOT ONLY AT STORES.
BUT ONLINE THE BIG ALLOCATE THE
SELLERS COULD IN FACT SELL THEIR
PRODUCTS ONLINE. WHAT TO DO
ONLINE TRIED TO DO THAT RIGHT
NOW THE KEY THING IS THAT THOSE
ONLINE SITES USE LICENSE
WHOLESALERS AND RETAILERS IN
CALIFORNIA TO FULFILL THOSE
REQUESTS. BOTH THE FALSE
NARRATIVE THAT SOMEHOW. SUMER IS
CAN'T FIND WHAT THEY WANT ONLINE
IS JUST NOT TRUE THIS FLY YOU
GOTTA CLOSE THE CABLE BILL BUT-
ALL RIGHT I WOULD JUST CLOSE
WITH SAYING THAT WE SUPPORT THE
CRAFT DISTILLERS. WE'D LIKE TO
HELP THEM IN A BILL THAT WOULD
SUPPORT THEM HELP THEM. AND
WE'RE ALSO SUPPORTED THE WHAT
THE CRAFT BREWERS WANT TO DO IN
TERMS OF LEGAL CLARIFICATION.
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS BILL DOES
A LOT MORE THAN THAT AND THAT'S
WHY WE'RE PROS. THANK YOU
FINALLY WE HAVE DENNIS LOPER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA BEER
AND BEVERAGE DISTRIBUTORS. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN DOUGLAS FLINT
BURNED OFFICE CVD. LIKE THE
LITTLE SPOKEN ALREADY HE
REPEATED HIS OPPOSITION
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LOSS OF GOOD
PAYING JOBS. AND LOTS OF
POTENTIAL REVENUE TO STATES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BUT WHAT
HASN'T BEEN DISCUSSED SINCE THE
IMPACT O RECYCLING BEER. UNLIKE
DISTILLED SPIRITS IS UP IS
REGULATED UNDER A GROUP. HEALTH
PLAN A RESPECT AND STATURE. S.
LABELING REQUIRE TO SEE EVERY.
COLLECTED THE LOCAL DISTRICT.
MANUFACTURING PROCESS FEE MY
QUESTION IS THE ARTISTIC CRAFT
BREWER SIMPLY TO CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS. GOING TO KNOW OR CARE
TO THESE REQUIREMENTS IS THIS
YEAR FOR YOUR SALES TAX.
PROPERLY OR IS THE YOUNG LADY
THE STREAMER GOING TO. RECEIVE A
BILL FOR THOSE TAXES OR FEES
THAT ARE DUE TO STATE OR LOCAL
OR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HI NOTE
SECTION SECTION TWO ABOUT. THAT
IT IS A MISDEMEANOR TO- BARLEY
TEA STATUTES INCLUDING RECEIVING
UNLICENSED PRODUCT MY QUESTION
IS WILL CONSUMERS KNOW THAT
THERE'S NOTHING IN SECTION TWO
OF THE BILL THAT SPEAKS TO THESE
ISSUES AGAIN WHY ARE WE HARMING
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
DISTRIBUTORS TO CREATE CONFUSION
OR REVENGE WHAT ELSE HER
NOTEBOOK. I THANK YOU APPRECIATE
THE MAIN OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WILL NOW MOVE TO ANY WITNESSES
IN THE CHAMBER AND I'VE SEEN
NONE. IT WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY.
VIA TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. NOW
THIS IS ONLY. WISHING TO TESTIFY
. IT OFFERS. TO SB SIX TWENTY.
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY. ONLY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB SIX TWENTY WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR- AGAIN TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
SIX TWENTY. AS A FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
ONE TWENTY. EXCUSE ME SB SIX
TWENTY ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME PLEASE WE WILL LINE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
FORTY YOUR OPEN. FORTY ONE MORE
TRY AND MEMBERS. YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU PLEASE PROCEED- MY NAME IS
JEROME LORI I'M A SALESMAN WITH
SOUTHERN GLAZIERS WHINING
SPIRITS I'M ALSO PROUD CANCERS
AND- YOU. REMEMBER I URGE YOU TO
VOTE NO ON SB SIX TWENTY. THANK
YOU LINE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY THIRTY ONE YOU ARE
OPEN. THE CHAIR MEMBERS MANY
JAMIE DIMON AND SALES REP AT
SOUTHERN GLAZER'S WINE SPIRITS
AND ALSO INTRODUCED REMEMBER
EARLIER NO VOTE SB SIX TWENTY
THANK YOU. LINE THIRTY FIVE YOUR
OPEN. THIRTY FIVE ARE YOU MUTED
. YEAH HI MY NAME IS TODD
ACKERMAN I'M A SALES REP IS W.
AS IN WINE AND SPIRITS AND I
OPPOSE SB SIX TWENTY. ONE THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING JAN MEMBER DADD GRANDMA
T THE UNITED FOOD AND
COMMERCIAL WORKERS WESTERN STATE
COUNCIL AND OPPOSITION THANK YOU
. NINE THIRTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTY EIGHT
ARE YOU MUTED. OKAY ONLINE SIXTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JEDIDIAH JOHNSON I'M A
BUSINESS REPRESENTATIVE FOR
TEAMSTERS LOCAL ONE EIGHTY SIX
F. B. SIX TWENTY WITH READ THE
JOB THE TEN THOUSAND EMPLOYEES-
OPPOSITION OR NOT AT LEAST ALL
RIGHT- NEXT FALL ON NBC TWENTY.
OPERATOR NINE ONE OH TWO
OPERATOR I'D LIKE YOU TO BE A
LITTLE MORE AGGRESSIVE AFTER
THEY SAY OPPOSITION AND THEY GO
ON PLEASE. MOVE TO THE NEXT
CALLER THANK YOU. NINE ONE OH TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WANT TO YOUR
OPEN. LIVING A LONG LINE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JEFF BREWER I
AM A SALES PERSON THAT SOUTHERN
GLAZIERS WHINING SPIRITS I AM
ALSO A PROUD TEAMSTERS MEMBER I
URGE YOUR NO VOTE ON SB SIX
TWENTY THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
LINE TWENTY TWO YOU ARE OPEN.
KAREN MEMBERS MY NAME IS FREDDIE
AREOLA AND I'M A COCKTAIL
CONSULTANT WITH SOUTHERN
GLAZIERS WHINING SPIRITS I'M
ALSO A PROUD TEAMSTER MEMBER AND
URGE YOUR NO VOTE AT THE SIX
TWENTY THANK YOU. FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
FRANCIS HUGHES I AM A SALES REP
WITH OUR NBC ALSO PROUD TEAMSTER
MEMBER FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS AND
I URGE YOUR VOTE NO ON SB SIX
TWENTY THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY FOUR
YOU ARE OPEN. SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
ON MUTE. MOVING ON OVER LIKE
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD-
GERMANTOWN COMMITMENT INTO THE
VASSAR I'VE BEEN IN SILICO YOU
WANTED SPIRITS IMPROMPTU TRIP
FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB SIX TWENTY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. BY ONE OH FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THERE IS A
REPUBLIC NATIONAL DISTRIBUTING
COMPANY AND I OPPOSE THANK YOU.
NINE THIRTY FOR YOUR OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS NICHOLAS LAST YEAR IT
. AND I WORK FOR SOUTHERN
GLAZER'S WINE AND SPIRITS. I AM
PROUD TO USE THEIR MEMBERS WELL
AND I URGE A NO VOTE ON SB SIX
TWENTY. THANK YOU. ONE SEVENTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH THAT YOUR
DAD MEMBERS MY NAME KATY HUDSON
I'M A SALES REPRESENTATIVE RD IN
A CROWD PETER AND I HEARD YOUR
NO VOTE ON SIX TWENTY. SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR UP. RESEARCHER
MEMBERS MY NAME IS TREVOR COOK
I'M A SALES REP IN OUR DC ALSO
PROTEINS REMEMBER AND I STRONGLY
URGE A NO VOTE ON SENATE BILL
SIX TWENTY THANK YOU. NINE
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS UP MY
NAME IS ERIC WILKEY AND I AM-
IT'S ALL IN THE SOUTHERN
GLAZER'S WINE AND SPIRITS I AM A
PROUD TEAMSTER MEMBER AND I URGE
A NO VOTE. ON SB SIX TWENTY.
THANK YOU. ONE ONE OH NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
MARSHALL LOOKED AT IN GREATER
DETAIL IN. A TEAM MEMBER AND I
OPPOSE. ALL NINE TWENTY THREE
YOUR OPEN. BY THE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JULIE
CHARACTER AND I AM A- WORKING
FOR THEM THANK YOU ONE AND I AM
A SALES CONSULTANT NINE ALSO A
CROWD HE NEEDS THEIR NUMBER AND
I URGE YOU KNOW A NO VOTE. ON SB
SIX TWENTY THANK YOU. MY TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ANDREW CRUISE AS A PROUD
TEAMSTER MAN YOUR MEMBER IN
SALES CONSULTANT AT SOUTHERN
GLAZER'S WINE AND SPIRITS I URGE
YOUR NO VOTE ON SB SIX TWENTY.
NINE ONE OH ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CHRIS TALKING ON THE FIELD HE
TOLD ME SEVEN GRANGER'S WAND.
I'M ALSO PROUD TEAMSTER MEMBER I
HEARD YOUR NO VOTE ON SB SIX
TWENTY THANK YOU. FINE THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DOMINIC IS OUR GOAL AND
THE PRODUCT TEAMSTER MEMBER AT
THE AT THAT. WHICH IS WHY IT'S
VERY SELF CONSULTANT I URGE YOU
TO VOTE NO ON SB SIX TWENTY.
THANK YOU MINE TOO THANK YOU ONE
TWENTY ONE. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DAVID PERCENT MALE I AM A SALES
CONSULTANT AT SEVEN GLAZER'S
WINE AND SPIRITS I'M ALSO PROUD
TEAMSTERS MEMBER AND I DO
STRONGLY URGE NO ON SB SIX
TWENTY. THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN DODD AND NUMBERS MY
NAME IS JAMES LOHAN SOUTHERN
PLAYERS WIND SPIRITS I AM A
PROUD TEAMSTER MEMBER I URGE YOU
KNOW ON BOTH SIX TWENTY SB SIX
POINT THANK YOU. THANK YOU LIKE
THIRTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS JEFF
HALE I'M WITH SOUTHERN GLAZER'S
pCONSULTANT I'M ALSO PROUD
TEAMSTERS MEANT NUMBER I URGE A
NO VOTE. ON SB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
THANK YOU. THANKS FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTY FIVE
YOUR OPEN ON MUTE PLEASE. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOHN
APPLET I'M A SALES PERSON OR IN
DC I'M ALSO PROUD TEAMSTER
MEMBER AND I URGE A NO VOTE ON
SB SIX TWENTY THANK YOU. FIVE
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE SEVENTY FIVE. GIVE ME
THAT'S A VERY YES PLEASE PROCEED
YEAH. GOOD MORNING THE CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS CHARLENE
GATHERED IN A PROBLEM FILLED F.
E. W. S. I HAVE BEEN WITH THE
COMPANY FOR THIRTY FOUR YEARS
AND I URGE YOU NO VOTE ON SB SIX
TWENTY. THANK YOU. FIVE SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEVENTY SIX
ARE YOU MUTED. HI MY NAME IS
CAROL HANSON I'M SEVEN GLACIER
WIND SPIRIT I'M A PROUD TEAMSTER
MEMBER FOR THE LAST TWENTY SEVEN
YEARS AND I'M URGING YOU TO VOTE
NO ON SB SIX TWENTY. ONE SEVENTY
NINE YOUR OUT. HELLO MISTER
CHAIRMAN YEAH HELLO MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
RYAN WOMEN. I WORK FOR SOUTHERN
GLAZIERS WHINING SPIRITS I'M
ALSO A PROUD TEAMSTER MEMBER I
URGE A NO VOTE ON SB SIX TWENTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CHRIS DYSON AND I AM A
SALES REPRESENTATIVE WITH ARE IN
DC AND I AM ALSO PROUD TEAMSTER
MEMBER AND I HEARD YOUR NO VOTE
ON SB SIX TWENTY. THANK THANK
YOU WHITE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I MEAN THAT YOU SHARE
NUMBERS- MY NAME IS JOSH FOURTH
I NEED SALES REP THAT SOMETHING
PLAYERS MORNING SPIRITS AS WELL
AS THE PROUD TEAMSTER MEMBERS I
DO URGE A NO VOTE ON SB SIX
TWENTY. THANK THANK YOU NINE
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING KAREN NUMBERS LET
ME SAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NINETY FOUR YOU ARE UP. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MIKE VELARDE AND I AM A
SALES CONSULTANT AT SOUTHERN
GLAZER'S WINE AND SPIRITS I'M
ALSO A PROUD TEAMSTER MEMBER I
HEARD YOUR NO VOTE ON SB SIX
TWENTY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. THE CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MICHAEL PAPPAS I'M A LIQUOR
SALESMAN SOMETHING LIKE THIS
ONE. I'M ALSO PROUD TO BE A
MEMBER I HEARD YOUR NO VOTE ON
SB SIX TWENTY THANK YOU. BUY A
NINETY FIVE. OH SKEWS ME LINE
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
VICTOR ALFA. BY LOCAL MAPS I
WORK FOR SOUTHERN MICHELIN
SPIRITS AND ALSO FROM TWELVE
TEAMSTERS MEMBER I READ YOUR
NOTE BOTH ON PAGE SIX TWENTY.
AND EXCLUDE THE LINE NINETY
SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. AARON
MEMBERS MY NAME IS GAINING ALONG
. SALES CONSULTANT FOR SOUTHERN
GLAZIERS WHINING SPIRITS I'M
ALSO PROUD TEAMSTER MEMBER AND I
ARCHER NO VOTE ON SB SIX TWENTY
. SURE THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP. THANK
YOU VERY VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE
THE- OPPOSITION WITNESSES- WE'RE
GONNA BRING THIS NOW BACK- TO
OUR MEMBERSHIP. ANY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE WISHING- TO
ADDRESS US FOR THIS BOARD US
SENATOR RUBIO SATTAR MIKE UP.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR. WELL FIRST
OF ALL I WANNA THANK EVERYONE
THAT CALLED IN TODAY- FIRST OF I
WANT TO START BY ACKNOWLEDGING
ALL THE CONCERNS OF BY ALL THE
TEAMSTERS ARE CALLED IN BUT ALSO
THE SMALL BUSINESSES AND I THINK
THERE'S A REAL CONCERN THERE AND
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO WORK ON BUT I ALSO WANT TO BE
MINDFUL AND THANKFUL THAT THE
AUTHOR HAS DEDICATED SO MUCH
TIME AT LEAST WITH ME WITH
HAVING CONVERSATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE WEEK AND- AND EVEN IN
PREVIOUS TIMES AND- HE HAS
AGREED TO CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION- IT'S VERY CLEAR
THAT THERE IS A LOT OF
DEFICIENCIES. A STATUS AND SO I
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT YOU KNOW I
LEASED IT FOR THE RECORD THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT SOME
OF THE ISSUES FACING THE
TEAMSTERS SMALL BUSINESSES
DEFINITIONS AND THERE'S A LOT A
LIST OF OTHER ITEMS THAT WE NEED
TO ADDRESS BUT TODAY I WILL
SUPPORT IT WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS
CONVERSATION WILL NOT STOP HERE
AND THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT
WE NEED TO ADDRESS BUT AGAIN I
WANT TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR
BECAUSE THAT'S BEEN HIS
COMMITMENT AND I KNOW THAT HE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS.
AND WHAT THAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR CENTER COME UNDER.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR- I. TWO. I
WANT TO ECHO THE- SENTIMENTS OF
MINE COLLEAGUE FROM ORLAND PARK
- I AM SUPPORTIVE OF THE INTENT
BEHIND THIS BILL I'VE HAD- GOOD
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL. AND I ALSO HAVE TO
SAY I HAVE FAITH IN THE AUTHOR.
THAT HE WILL DO ALL THAT HE CAN-
TO WORK THIS OUT. HE HAS PROVEN
TO BE THAT KIND OF CHAMPION- FOR
OTHER ISSUES AND SO I CERTAINLY
DON'T THINK THAT HE WILL NOT-
GIVE THE SAME KIND OF ATTENTION
TO THIS ISSUE. I'VE HEARD THAT
THERE WERE CONSTRUCTIVE
DISCUSSIONS EVEN THIS MORNING
WITH THE OPPOSITION AND I DO
BELIEVE THAT- THINGS WILL GET
WORKED OUT. YOU KNOW I YOU WOULD
THINK I WOULD HAVE KNOWN MORE
ABOUT THIS ISSUE BECAUSE I
CERTAINLY INVITES. ARE BUT- I
DON'T KNOW THAT MUCH ABOUT THIS
ISSUE I DID READ THE LANGUAGE
AND I READ THE ANALYSIS AND I
READ MANY OF THE SUPPORT LETTERS
AND LISTENED OBVIOUSLY TO THE
FOLKS WHO CALLED IN ON BOTH
SIDES. AND A FEW THOUGHTS WERE
RAISED- THAT THE LANGUAGE
ACTUALLY DOESN'T DISCRIMINATE
BETWEEN LARGE AND SMALL
DISTILLERIES WHICH IN MY MIND
MEANS THAT SMALL DISTILLERIES-
WILL LOSE OUT I MEAN JUST
BECAUSE OF. YOU KNOW WHO HAS A
GREATER SHARE OF THE MARKET WHO
HAS MORE CAPACITY MORE CAPITAL
GREATER INFRASTRUCTURE I THINK
WE OWE IT TO OURSELVES TO TRY TO
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE TO OUR SMALL AND
FAMILY RUN IN CALIFORNIA
DISTILLERIES. EVEN THOUGH I KNOW
THERE ARE SOME ISSUES BETWEEN IN
STATE OUT OF STATE AND HOW YOU
CAN'T DISCRIMINATE- AT THE END
OF THE DAY IT SEEMS TO ME FROM
WHAT I'VE READ THAT DISTRIBUTORS
ACTUALLY. DON'T SEEM TO WANT TO
WORK WITH SMALL DISTILLERIES
BECAUSE IT PROBABLY DOESN'T
PENCIL OUT. IN YOU KNOW MY
RESPONSE IS SHAME ON THEM- I
THINK WE OWE IT TO. OUR CRAFT
DISTILLERIES ESPECIALLY THOSE-
HERE IN CALIFORNIA TO FIGURE OUT
A WAY TO INCENTIVIZE OR
ENCOURAGE DISTRIBUTORS TO WORK
WITH THEM SO THAT WE CAN LEVEL
THE PLAYING FIELD SO THAT
CONSUMERS HAVE. ALL OPTIONS AT
THEIR DISPOSAL TO BE SUPPORTIVE%
OF SOME OF THE GREAT PRODUCTS
THAT ARE COMING OUT OF THE STATE
IN THAT ARE COMING FROM OUR
SMALL CRAFT DISTILLERIES. N. YOU
KNOW WE HEARD FROM FOLKS ON WHO
SUPPORT THE BILL THAT THIS WILL
CREATE JOBS BUT WE ALSO HEARD
FROM FOLKS IN OPPOSITION. THAT
DOGS WILL BE LOST AND I DO THINK
WE OWE IT TO BOTH SIDES TO KIND
OF FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
COMPROMISES. BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE
DON'T WANT MORE JOBS TO
DISAPPEAR AND WE DON'T WANT.
JOBS THAT ARE GOOD THAT DON'T
HAVE BENEFITS THAT DON'T ALLOW
FOLKS TO RAISE THEIR FAMILIES
AND CARE FOR THEIR FAMILIES. WE
DON'T WANT THOSE KINDS OF JOBS
TO BE LOST. SO I AM RESPECTFULLY
GONNA. LAY OFF AT THIS TIME
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT THIS WILL
GET OUT AND I WANT THE
DISCUSSIONS TO CONTINUE. AND I
INTEND TO BE ABLE TO VOTE ON A
BILL WHEN IT COMES UP FOR ME
AGAIN BECAUSE I AS I MENTIONED
AT THE BEGINNING HAVE FAITH. IN
THIS AUTHOR- THAT HE I GOING TO
DO WHAT I THINK HE'S ALREADY
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO DO
BUT IT WAS PROBABLY JUST TIMING.
FOR WHEN THIS BILL WAS BEING
HEARD. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
MEMBERS- CENTER THE BARGES
PLEASE. SHARE EDUCATION A CHAT
WITH THE AUTHOR AND I GOTTA TELL
YA I HOLD THE AUTHOR IN THE
HIGHEST ESTEEM ARE BECAUSE HE'S
A VERY THOUGHTFUL HAS A HISTORY
OF WORKING WITH FOLKS AND-
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT PASS
FORWARD I THINK WE'RE LOOKING AT
A BILL THAT HAS SOME UNEXPECTED
COMPLEXITY AND CERTAINLY-
DIVISION OF SPECIAL. INTERESTS
BEING FROM FRESNO- NO DOUBT WE
HAVE A STRONG DISTRIBUTION
NETWORK SYSTEM IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY- ONE THAT I THINK HAS
BEEN ESSENTIAL TO OUR ECONOMIC
PROSPERITY- BUT REVIEWING THIS
MATTER I THINK WE CAN ALL
APPRECIATE THAT THE THREE TIERED
SYSTEM. IS A LITTLE ARCHAIC AND
IT NEEDS TO BE REVIEWED AND
LOOKED AFTER- INTO WHAT IT'S
LIKE FOR INDUSTRY MOVING FORWARD
ESPECIALLY WITH LESSONS LEARNED
FROM COVERT- BECAUSE WE'RE STILL
REALIZING. HELLO INDUSTRY HAS
BEEN IMPACTED BY THAT AND HOW WE
HAVE BEEN NIMBLE. IN ALLOWING
OUR ALCOHOL SALES DIRECTLY TO
CONSUMERS- IN WAYS THAT ARE BOTH
YOU KNOW CONVENIENT AND- IN
RESOLVABLE FROM A- FROM A LEGAL
STANDPOINT. OF THIS SITUATION
IS- A LITTLE UNUSUAL I HAVE A
HISTORY OF SUPPORTING OUR CRAFT
BREWERS- WINERIES- DISTILLERIES
BY IN MY DISTRICT I THINK IT YOU
KNOW FOOD PRODUCTS. ARE ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE CAN- FURTHER
DEVELOP BECAUSE CALIFORNIA IS A
SPECIAL BRAND WE HAVE SPECIAL
QUALITIES AND- WE CAN SELL NOT
JUST. WITHIN THE US- BUT
CERTAINLY- ABROAD- WITH THE WITH
THE WITH WITH GREAT SUCCESS. BUT
I TOOK A LOOK AT THIS GRAND HOME
DECISION AND THE COMMERCE CLAUSE
MY FIRST INSTINCT WAS. WE WANT
TO PROTECT THIS- SMALL BATCH.
DISTILLERIES AND BREWERIES- THAT
WE'D FIND A WAY TO LOOK AFTER
THE BUDDING INDUSTRIES IN
CALIFORNIA- THE SUPREME COURT
DECISION IN GRAHAM HOME-
INDICATES THAT- THERE MUST BE
PARITY BETWEEN IN AND OUT OF
STATE SALES OF FOR PURPOSES OF
THE COMMERCE CLAUSE. AND I WENT
BACK TO MY OLD LAW SCHOOL DAYS
AND BEGAN TO FULLY APPRECIATE
AND THEN CAME ACROSS THE
KENTUCKY RULE- THAT. GOT AROUND
THE GRAND HOME DECISION IN THE
COMMERCE CLAUSE BUT LIMITING- TO
TEN LEADERS- FOR EACH CONSUMER.
AND SO I THINK THERE ARE WAYS TO
LOOK AFTER IT AND DEVELOP OUR
DISTILLERIES. BUT WE ALSO HAVE
TO LOOK AFTER WAYS THAT WERE
IMPACTING THE MARKET.
DISTRIBUTION NETWORKS ARE NOT
CHEAP. IT TAKES DRIVERS IT TAKES
TRUCKS IT TAKES CENTER. IT TAKES
THE G. SIX ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
INVESTMENT AND IF YOU'RE GOING
TO INJECT UNCERTAINTY INTO THE
MARKET ESPECIALLY IN A POST CODE
SITUATION YOU HAVE TO APPRECIATE
THE COMPLICATIONS AND
IMPLICATIONS. OF YOUR
INVOLVEMENT. I THINK THIS IS A
THAT WAR. MORE DISCUSSION. I
THINK THERE'S A PATH FORWARD
HERE YOU KNOW WHETHER IT IS
DROPPING IT DOWN AND I'D LIKE TO
HEAR FROM THE AUTHOR IN ANY OF
MY OTHER COLLEAGUES. THERE SEEMS
TO BE WAYS THAT WE CAN- THAT WE
CAN. ACHIEVE WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE WHILE STILL LOOKING AFTER
THE GOOD PAYING JOBS OF FOLKS
THAT WORK IN THE DISTRIBUTION
SYSTEM THE FOLKS THAT'LL THAT
OWN AND OPERATE. THE
DISTRIBUTION NETWORKS- THIS IS
NOT A ZERO SUM GAME WITH WINNERS
AND LOSERS I THINK THIS COULD BE
A WIN WIN SITUATION. BUT THE WAY
THAT IT'S DRAFTED RIGHT NOW. I'M
AFRAID THERE ARE THERE ARE SO
MANY LEGAL QUESTIONS THAT I'M
JUST NOW FOR MORE FULLY
APPRECIATIVE OF ON FOR EXAMPLE
THE CALIFORNIA DEFINITION OF
CRAFT. AND A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND GALLONS YOU KNOW IS
THAT LIMITED TO THE PRODUCTION
OF THE FACILITY OR IS THAT
LIMITED TO THE SPECIFIC LINE
ITEM- AND ALL USE THE EXAMPLE
OF. YOU KNOW IF A PARENT
COMPANY- HAS MULTIPLE SMALL
BATCH- SUBSIDIARIES YOU KNOW IS
IT LIMITED TO THE VODKA. AS
OPPOSED TO THE RASPBERRY VODKA.
SO THERE'S A NUMBER OF LEGAL
ISSUES HERE THAT I WOULD LIKE
TIME TO TIBET TO BETTER
APPRECIATE MAYBE THE AUTHOR AND
POTENTIALLY THE CO AUTHOR CHAIR
OF THIS COMMITTEE- CAN CAN- LINE
THIS UP BETTER BUT- I THINK IF
WE WERE TO. CONSIDER DROPPING
DOWN THE- THE VOLUME TO A TO A
RATE THAT DOES NOT AFFECT THE
SUPERMARKETS AND THE RETAILERS
THAT ARE SELLING YOU KNOW
NORMALLY THE LARGE BRAND ITEMS
BUT YOU CREATE A SITUATION WHERE
SALES NUMBERS CAN MAKE A SMALL
BATCH BREWERIES AND DISTILLERIES
ATTRACTIVE TO GET ON THE SHELF.
THAT COULD HELP OUR INTREPID
NOURIEL DOT SET OF INDUSTRIES-
SO I DON'T KNOW IF THE AUTHOR
HAS ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR EVEN
MY COLLEAGUES BUT THIS IS A WORK
IN PROGRESS. IN NORMALLY I DON'T
LIKE VOTING ON ON THINGS THAT
HAVE SO MUCH TO DO BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO HEAR. FROM OTHER FOLKS
AND SEE IF THERE IS A WAY. FOR
THIS TO BE A WIN WIN SITUATION
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S JUST ABOUT
THINKING IT THROUGH AND HAVING
MORE DISCUSSION. SEVERAL FIRST
OF ALL I WANT TO FAKE THANK YOU
CENTER FOR JUST FOR THOSE
COMMENTS AND OBVIOUSLY THANKS TO
MY- MY OTHER COLLEAGUES HAVE
SPOKEN SO FAR- THERE THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT WE'RE IN THE WE'RE
NOT INTERESTED IN HARMING SMALL
BUSINESS WE'RE NOT INTERESTED IN
HARMING OUR JOBS- IN MANY
RESPECTS I THINK THE IDEA BEHIND
THIS BILL IF YOU LOOK AT THE
WINE INDUSTRY WE'VE DISCUSSED
THIS. THE WHEN SO MY FRIEND FROM
LOS ANGELES AND A CALLER SAID
SHAME ON ON THE ON THE ON THE
DISTRIBUTORS FOR NOT. DOING MORE
TO HELP OUT THE SMALL PRODUCERS-
I THINK SHE ANSWERED HER OWN
CONCERN WHICH HE SAID THAT THE
END OF THE DAY THOSE SMALL
PRODUCTS THEY JUST DON'T PENCIL
OUT THE DISTRIBUTORS ARE REALLY
FOCUSED ON ON THE BIG VERY
POPULAR PRODUCTS THAT ARE TRIED
AND TRUE AND AS THEY SHOULD BE
RIGHT I MEAN THAT'S THAT'S THEIR
BUSINESS MODEL IS MAKING MONEY
SELLING AND DISTRIBUTING.
DISTRIBUTING ARE THOSE TRIED AND
TRUE PRODUCTS AND WHAT ENDS UP
HAPPENING IS IT'S HARD FOR SMALL
NICHE PRODUCTS TO BREAK IN TO
THE MARKET WHAT'S HAPPENED WITH
ONE OF COURSE IS THAT FOLKS GO
TO HONOR THE FALLEN LOVE WITH
THE WITH THE WITH THE PARTICULAR
TYPE OF WINE AND THEY START TO
BUY THE WINE THE WORD GETS OUT
ABOUT THE WINE AND NEXT THING
YOU KNOW THE ONE CONNECTS HER TO
GROW IN POPULARITY AND AT SOME
POINT THE DISTRICT WILL PICK IT
UP BECAUSE THEY RECOGNIZE THAT-
IT'S A IT'S A IT'S A POPULAR
COLOR NOT LUCKY TAKE A CHANCE ON
THE WIND. OUT THE GATE- THERE'S
SO MANY GREAT CRAFT WINE
PRODUCERS IN DISTILLERS AND BEER
PRODUCERS ALL ALL THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND- AND YOU KNOW HOW WHAT
WHY WHY WOULD THEY POSSIBLY TAKE
A CHANCE ON A SMALL ONE IN
LESSER SOME KIND OF INCENTIVE
WAS TRADED TO PRODUCTS THAT'S
WHAT THIS IS OPENLY ABOUT BEING
UP IN SPACE FOR THOSE PRODUCTS
TO GET OUT. TO CONSUMERS SO THAT
WHEN SOMEONE GOES TO A DEALER
THEY GO TO- A BREWERY AND THEY
FALL IN LOVE WITH A PARTICULAR
PRODUCT AND THEN I PROBABLY NEED
TO BE THE CARD STORE THEY CAN
FIND A WAY TO GET THE PRODUCT IN
THE FUTURE DIRECTLY SHIPPED. TO
THAT. NOW I. CLEARLY I A YOU
KNOW THE- GUYS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHAT WILL I'M TALKING.
SMALL THIS. AND SMALL PRODUCER.
AND THE WAY BILLS RIGHT RIGHT.
IT APPLIES TO EVERYBODY. AND I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S A LOT OF
FOLKS OUT THERE WHO WHO WANT TO
LIMIT- SO I DO THINK THERE'S NO
QUESTION MY MIND THE BILL WE'RE
GONNA TO GO FURTHER AND LIMITING
THE NUMBER OF BOTTLES- PER
PERSON PER MONTH THAT WE HAVE A
CRAFT RIGHT NOW IT'S SET AT THE
KENTUCKY STANDARD. I'M HEARING
FROM FOLKS THAT WE NEED TO KNOCK
THAT NUMBER DOWN I'M ACTUALLY
HAPPY TO DO THAT- YOU KNOW SO
THAT'S ONE THING. THE OTHER
THING IS. THE DISTINCTION
BETWEEN BIG PRODUCERS AND SMALL
PRODUCERS AND SMALL PRODUCT. AND
HERE THE OTHER DAY MY FOCUS IS
REALLY ON ON TRYING TO PROVIDE.
MORE OPPORTUNITIES MORE ACCESS.
FOR FOR THE SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT ARE PRODUCING THESE. THESE
FANTASTIC ARTISANAL PRODUCTS-
YOU KNOW THERE IS A CONSUMER
EQUITY QUESTION ASSOCIATED WITH.
THE CURRENT SYSTEM AND- AND THE
ISSUES THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
RESOLVE WITH THIS BILL. BUT
SUFFICE TO SAY I YOU KNOW I
CAN'T SEE THIS BILL. COULD GET
HOW THIS LEGISLATURE WITHOUT-
WITH WITHOUT OUR REALLY REALLY.
CONFINING V. VIS. A DIRECT
CONSUMER. OFFER TO TWO SMALL
SMALL BATCH PRODUCTION. I THINK
I THINK. THAT WILL ULTIMATELY
RESOLVE THE CORE OPPOSITION
CONCERNS WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
TEAMSTERS AND THE GROCERS IN THE
DISTILLERS WHO IN IT. THAT'S
RIGHT THE DISTRIBUTORS. WHO OF
COURSE IN THE END THEY ARE
REALLY FOCUSED ON THE BIG. THE
BIG PRODUCTS. I SAY. I YOU KNOW
MOST ARE ABLE TO GOING TO- YOU
KNOW. WHAT WHAT WHY WOULD THEY
WANT TO TELL THE EXTRA SHIPPING
WHEN THEY CAN GO DOWN TO THE
CORNER STORE AND BUY THE PRODUCT
THE MAKER'S MARK DOWN THE CORNER
STORE- WHEN THEY CAN YOU KNOW
THE SO I DO THINK THAT THIS THIS
CONCERN HAS BEEN RAISED ABOUT
HOW THIS IS GOING TO COLLAPSE
THE SYSTEM IS JUST TOTALLY
OVERBLOWN IT'S HYPERBOLIC I JUST
DON'T BELIEVE IT'S TRUE BUT I
UNDERSTAND THAT PEOPLE ARE. YOU
KNOW ALWAYS GOING TO BE CONCERNS
ABOUT ANY KINDS OF CHANGES IN IN
IN IN THE REGULATORY SYSTEM SO.
I I'M ASKING MY COLLEAGUES TO
GIVE US THE CHANCE. TO FIGURE
OUT A PASSWORD WITH THIS BILL.
THAT WILL. THAT WILL FOCUS ON
OUR ULTIMATE INTENT WHICH IS TO
ALLOW FOR SPACE. FOR HIGH
QUALITY. EXCITING ARTISANAL
PRODUCTS. TO EXPAND MARKETS TO
EXPAND ACCESS. TO CONSUMERS WHO
RIGHT NOW HAVE NO WAY OF GETTING
THE PRODUCT. IF YOU IF YOU COME
FROM. SENATOR JONES IS OFFICE
DISTRICT AND YOU'RE UP IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA VISITING THE
CAPITAL YOU VISIT A DISTILLER.
YOU LOVE THE PRODUCT THAT YOU-
THAT YOU FIND HERE. YOU
LITERALLY YOU CAN BUY MAYBE A
COUPLE BOTTLES AT THE AT THE AT
THE AT THE AT THIS AT THE SHOP
HERE. BUT YOU THEN THERE'S NO
WAY YOU CAN ACCESS THE PRODUCT
WAS YOU PHYSICALLY COME
YOURSELF. UP HERE TO GET THAT
PRODUCT AGAIN THAT'S JUST CRAZY.
WE OUGHT TO FIND A WAY TO ALLOW
THAT CONSTITUENT FROM ANOTHER
PART OF THE STATE. TO BE ABLE TO
BUY. A SMALL BIT REASONABLE
AMOUNT OF THAT PRODUCT FROM THE
OTHER PART OF THE STATE. OR THE
OTHER PART OF THE COUNTRY. IT'S
IN THE WAY WE HAVE ACROSS RIGHT
NOW IS TO SELL A ANTI CONSUMER.
AND I'M ASKING COLLEAGUES FOR
YOU TO GIVE US THE OPPORTUNITY
TO. TO CRAFT A SOLUTION WE'RE
GOING TO WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH.
FOLKS IN THE TEAMSTERS AND FROM
THE DISTRIBUTORS AND FROM THE
GROUP. AND THE R. C. W. IN
ADDITION TO THE DISTILLERS AND
THE PRODUCERS. TO COME UP WITH
SOME SOLUTION THAT WILL. GIVE
MORE CONSUMER ACCESS. FOR THESE
EXCITING NEW PRODUCTS. OUT
WITHOUT HARMING LOCAL BUSINESS
WITHOUT HARMING. LOCAL JOBS
ABBOTT BUT ALLOWING FOR THE
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT ARE
PRODUCING REALLY GREAT PRODUCTS
YOU. TO EXPAND. THEIR ACCESS TO
THE MARKETS. THANK YOU. SO WE
NEED WE HAVE CENTER WILL SEND A
REPORT TO NOTE SENATOR BRADFORD
THAT- ALL WANT TO SPEAK TO THIS
ISSUE. AND IT'S EVERYBODY'S
DEVELOPING THEIR THOUGHTS ON
THIS BILL I THOUGHT I'D TAKE AN
OPPORTUNITY RIGHT NOW TO OFFER
MY REMARKS NOW INSTEAD OF. LATER
I WANT TO THANK CENTER OUR FOR
TAKING ON THIS REALLY
COMPLICATED ISSUE. AS MEMBERS
KNOWS THIS BILL HAS BEEN IN
PRINT SINCE MARCH OF LAST YEAR.
SENATOR ALLEN AGREED TO THE
HEARING ON THE BILL WITH A
COMMITMENT FROM THE COMMITTEE TO
HOLD AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
DURING OUR FALL RECESS. THE
INFORMATION HEARING WAS HELD IN
NOVEMBER WHERE I MADE IT CLEAR
THAT WE WOULD BE HEARING THIS
BILL. IN JANUARY. I WOULD HOPE
THAT WE WOULD MAKE MORE PROGRESS
OVER THE COURSE OF THE LAST NINE
MONTHS. AND CERTAINLY OVER THE
LAST MONTH AND A HALF. HOWEVER
CENTER I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS. THAT ARE
HERE TODAY TO ALIGN WITH THE
DISTILLED SPIRIT LIMITATIONS
THOSE CURRENTLY IN PLACE IN
KENTUCKY. I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
LIMITATION- SOMETHING FITTED
LIMITATIONS TOO HIGH MAYBE IT IS
. BUT I HOPE BY TAKING INITIAL
STEPS WITH ENOUGH VOTES TO GET
THIS OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY THE
BOTH SIDES WILL COME TOGETHER TO
HOPEFULLY FIND SOMETHING THAT
BOTH SIDES CAN FEEL COMFORTABLE
WITH. IN THAT SPIRIT OF
COLLABORATION WITH YOUR
PERMISSION SENATOR I WOULD LIKE
TO JOIN YOU WITH A JOINT OFFER.
I HOPE THAT IN DOING SO WE CAN
PRESS TO BOTH SUPPORTERS AND
OPPONENTS THAT WE'RE ABSOLUTELY
COMMITTED TO THE ISSUE THIS
ISSUE. I HEARD TODAY IN THE
HEARING. AFTER MR LOW PURCHASE
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE TAX ISSUE
ON BEER. THAT RESONATED WITH ME
I'VE HEARD ABOUT THE LARGE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE JOBS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE THE NEGATIVE
THINGS THAT COULD HAPPEN WITH
THAT. THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IS
EASILY ADDRESS AND FINALLY YOU
HEARD FROM THE AUTHOR TODAY THAT
THE QUANTITY ISSUE WILL
ABSOLUTELY BE ADDRESSED AND I
AGREE. WITH THAT THIS IS- IOTA
CENTER YOU AND I'VE HAD PLENTY
OF CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHAT THIS
POSSIBLY COULD LOOK LIKE IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT WE NEED TO GET
BOTH SIDES REALLY SERIOUS ABOUT
WORKING TOGETHER. AND THAT'S WHY
THE VOTES ON THE FLOOR TODAY ARE
SO INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY WITH
YOUR COMMITMENT SURROUNDED
CONTINUE WORKING WITH ME. TO GET
THROUGH THE PROCESS TO WORK WITH
BOTH SIDES AND COME TO THE
FLOOR. IN THE- PERHAPS EVEN
BEFORE IT GETS TO THE FLOOR WE
CAN WORK WITH I'M MAKING NO
COMMITMENTS VIEWS A CENTER
REPORT TO YOU KNOW. BUT WE CAN
WORK WITH THE CENTER AND A YOU
KNOW IN APPROPRIATIONS TO GET
SOME OF THIS DONE BEFORE IT
COMES TO THE FORE SO WITH THAT
I'LL MOVE TO CENTER UP AND QUIT.
I WANT TO BUILD ON THE ICE I ONE
THING I DO WANT TO SAY I DO WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES I MEAN
SENATOR RUBIO FOR EXAMPLE WE HAD
EXTENSIVE CONVERSATIONS WHERE
SHE LAID OUT CONCERNS. WITH THE
BILL LOOK MUCH MUCH ALONG THE
LINES OF WHAT WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING IN IN SESSION HERE
TODAY- SO MANY OF YOU HAVE DUG
IN REALLY DEEP AND REALLY TRY TO
GRAPPLE WITH WHAT OUR INTENT IS
HERE WITH ALSO THE CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN RACE I JUST WANNA
THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR THE
THOUGHTFUL AND ENGAGEMENT. THE
YOU'VE HAD I WANT TO WELCOME
THAT ENGAGEMENT AS AS AS THE
BILL CONTINUES THANK YOU CENTER
REPORTING. TO YOU KNOW SORRY TO
MAKE YOU WAIT SIR. NO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- AND THE OBVIOUS
THEY WANT TO. THE THANK YOUR-
LEADERSHIP IN IT BUT- WITH THE
AMENDMENTS AND CERTAINLY
COMPLEMENT THE AUTHOR- FOR BEING
OPEN IN THE CONVERSATION AND-
AND- TAKING THE HEART. BOTH THE
INTERESTS OF OUR SMALL BUSINESS-
NEEDS AND THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED- THIS BILL WILL BE
COMING TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE NEXT- SO I'M- GOING TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY- WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT THOSE FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS WILL CONTINUE. AND
THAT THEY'LL BE A SECOND BITE AT
THE APPLE TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THAT WHATEVER DOES COME TO THE
FLOOR- IS IN THE RIGHT. PLACE TO
RESPECT AND ENCOURAGE
ENTREPRENEURSHIP THAT'S BEEN
MADE MENTION. AND ALSO THE
CONCERNS. ON THE OPPOSITION AS
WELL SO. WITH THAT I'LL SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY. AND APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK THAT THE CHAIR AND
MR ALLEN HAVE DONE. AND
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS- THAT
HAVE BEEN EXPRESSED TODAY BY
BOTH SIDES- SO. LOOKING FORWARD
TO FINDING THAT SWEET SPOT AS WE
MOVE FORWARD SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR AT CENTRE BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT
TO THANK ALL OF THE- THE
WITNESSES WHO TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT AND IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE. AND IT'S ONE. THAT
WARRANTS THE LOCAL DISCUSSION
THAT WE'VE HAD SO FAR AND I FIND
MYSELF IN A VERY UNIQUE POSITION
BECAUSE I HAVE. SMALL CRAFT
DISTILLERS IN MY DISTRICT AS
WELL AS THE LARGEST AFRICAN
AMERICAN DISTRIBUTOR IN THIS
COUNTRY AND MY DISTRICT. AND
THEY BOTH HAVE EXPRESSED
CONCERNS. IN REGARDS TO THIS
MEASURE ALSO EXPRESSED THE
BENEFITS THAT COULD BE AFFORDED
TO THEM. BECAUSE OF THIS MEASURE
BUT AS- HAS BEEN SAID BY MANY OF
MY OTHER COLLEAGUES ARE STILL A
LOT OF UNANSWERED. QUESTIONS AND
I HAVE NO DOUBT THE INTENTIONS
OF THIS AUTHOR AND WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE HERE WITH THIS
MEASURE. BUT IT LEAVES ME IN A
POSITION WHERE I AM NOT READY TO
VOTE NO FOR THIS MEASURE BUT AT
THE SAME TIME I'M NOT READY TO
VOTE YES AND I WOULD HOPE. THAT
THOSE ISSUES THAT ARE STILL
PENDING WILL BE WORKED OUT AND
SO WE CAN HAVE. A MEASURE THAT
TRULY ACHIEVES THE GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES THAT HAVE BEEN SENT
OUT- AND INTENTIONS BECAUSE-
AGAIN I'VE HEARD FROM BOTH SIDES
AND I WANT TO BE FAIR HRE AND I
JUST THINK RIGHT NOW I'M NOT
COMFORTABLE WITH WHERE WE FIND
OURSELVES RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU
SENATOR- CENTER WILL. THANK YOU
MR CHAIR- I DON'T WANT TO BEAT A
DEAD HORSE BECAUSE I THINK THAT
SENATOR BARGES- COMPLETELY
ARTICULATED WHERE I'M AT THERE'S
OPPORTUNITIES WITH THIS BILL AS
WELL AS CHALLENGES I'M PRO
CONSUMER BUT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT HAVING AN IMPACT ON THE
THREE THREE TIERED SYSTEM I KNOW
THAT WE'RE UP AGAINST A
LEGISLATIVE DEADLINE I ALSO HAVE
GREAT FAITH IN THE AUTHOR AND
THIS COMMITTEE CHAIR- SO I
INVENTED BOTH TO MOVE THE BILL
TODAY. AND RESERVE RIGHT- TO
CHANGE MY MIND IF WE GO BY AND
THEN WHATEVER THAT SWEET SPOT IS
I THINK IT'S STILL PROBABLY A
LITTLE BIT TOO BROAD BUT I'M
HOPEFUL- WITH BOTH SIDES COMING
TOGETHER THAT WE CAN REACH A
CONSENSUS THAT'S GOING TO
BENEFIT EVERYONE SO. THOSE ARE
THOSE ARE MY COMMENTS TODAY
THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU SENATOR
SENATOR JONES THANK YOU MR CHAIR
AND- MR ALLEN. YOU KNOW IT'S NOT
OFTEN THAT- YOU KNOW ON BILLS
LIKE THIS AND I'M AUTHORED YOU
KNOW BILLS FOR THE CRAFT
BREWERIES AND FOR THE CRAFT
DISTILLERS- AND SO I THINK YOU
KNOW WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE AS
FAR AS THAT. AND I RARELY HEAR
FROM MY- DISTRICT CONSTITUENTS
ON THESE ISSUES BUT I WILL LET
YOU KNOW THAT- ON THIS
PARTICULAR BILL THE WAY IT'S
CURRENTLY CRAFTED- MY PHONE AND
EMAIL HAS BLOWN UP. WITH
CONCERNS FROM MY LOCAL
CONSTITUENTS SO- I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO GETTING TO A POINT
WHERE I CAN SEE YOU. IN OFFICE I
HAVE A BILL THAT WE CAN SUPPORT
IT I'M GONNA MAKE A COMMITMENT
TO THE AUTHOR THAT IN THE
MEANTIME I'M GONNA. HOLD A TOWN
HALL MEETING WITH THE- MY LOCAL
CONDITIONS THAT ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS BILL. AND SEE IF YOU
KNOW I CAN- YOU KNOW ARTICULATE
SOME OF THE CONCERNS. AND ANSWER
SOME OF THEIR CONCERNS THAT THEY
HAVE REGARDING THIS SO THAT-
THERE'S A COMFORT LEVEL WITH HIM
MY CONSTITUENTS. HOW TO MOVE
FORWARD SO IT TODAY I'LL BE
LAYING OFF BUT I'M I'M GOING TO.
WORK IN MY OWN DISTRICT TO MAKE
SURE THAT I CAN. COMMUNICATE
WITH MY CONSTITUENTS TO HELP OUT
ON THIS ISSUE. ANY OTHER MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK. SEEING NONE-
SEVERAL MUCH LIKE WHAT'S IT
SKEWS ME CENTER ARCHULETA. HERE
I'M GOING TO HOLD OFF TODAY- I
FEEL THAT THEY'RE SO CLOSE I'VE
TALKED TO BOTH SIDES AND I GET
THE FEELING THAT THEY'RE VERY
CLOSE AND I THINK WE SHOULD JUST
LET THEM COME TOGETHER SO- FROM
WHAT WE HEARD FROM MY
COLLEAGUES- I JUST CAN'T GO
FORWARD WITH IT RIGHT NOW BUT
WHEN IT- WHEN THEY COME TOGETHER
AND I KNOW THEY WILL IT SEEMS
LIKE IT IT SEEMS LIKE OUR
AUTHORS. IS DETERMINED TO GET
TOGETHER AND I THINK WE CAN DO
THAT. SO I'LL BE HOLDING OFF
TODAY. THE OTHER ANYBODY ELSE.
SEE NON CENTER ALOE WHICH I
CLOSE. I WOULD RESPECT
COLLEAGUES ON IT'S HARD TO GET
PEOPLE TOGETHER IF YOU ALL HOLD
OFF- YOU KNOW WE ARE UP AGAINST
A DEADLINE AND LIFT THIS
DEADLINES NOT THIS THAT WE
VOLUNTARILY HELD THIS BILL BACK
LAST YEAR SO AS TO ALLOW FOR
TIME. IN THE PROCESS ARE WE HELD
A HEARING- WE'VE YOU KNOW THAT
THE OPPOSITION IS COMING IN AS
IS TYPICAL YOU KNOW VERY VERY
LATE AND HEAVY JUST OVER THE
LAST TWENTY FOUR HOURS I
UNDERSTAND- YOU KNOW IT IT IT'S
I UNDERSTAND THE PRESSURE THAT
THE FOLKS ARE UNDER. THIS IS A
THIS IS A CONCEPT THAT IS WILDLY
POPULAR MEXICAN AMOUNTS ARE
CONSTITUENTS OF YOU WERE TO ASK
CONSTITUENTS YOU KNOW- I YOU
SHOULD YOU BE ABLE TO GO. OUR
FOLLOW THE PRODUCT AND THEN TO
HAVE IT SHIPPED DIRECTLY TO YOU
IF IT'S NOT AVAILABLE AT YOUR
LOCAL STORE. EVERYONE'S GOING TO
SAY YES AND YET. I KNOW I
UNDERSTAND IT'S STILL HARD TO
GET THESE KINDS OF BILLS PASSED
IN THE LEGISLATURE. HI I'M
ASKING YOU TO GIVE US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO KEEP WORKING ON
THIS- THIS IS ULTIMATELY PROCHAN
SIMMER BILL. AND WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO FINDING
AN EQUITABLE SOLUTION THAT WILL
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF OUR
FRIENDS FROM LABOR ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS IN THE SMALL BUSINESS
COMMUNITY THE GROCERS. AND
DISTRIBUTORS I THINK THERE'S A
PATH HERE. AND I ASK YOU TO GIVE
US THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ON ON
DEVELOPING A DEVICE IN THAT PATH
AS IT GOES THE APPROPRIATIONS
PROCESS AND THEN ON. SO WITHOUT
I RESPECT RESTAURANT A VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN I BELIEVE
CENTER PORT TINO DID YOU HAVE
SOMETHING ELSE TO SAY I'M SORRY
I MISSED YOU ON THE SCREEN HERE
. NOW I JUST FORGOT TO PUT MY
HAND DOWN THANK YOU SIR. OKAY
WITH THAT- THE MOTION IS TO PASS
A MINUTE IT'S A- TWO
APPROPRIATIONS THE- DO WE HAVE A
MOTION FIRST. SENATOR RUBIO
MOVED THE MOTION MOVES THE BILL
SB SIX TWENTY. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS THE F. B. SIX TWENTY OUR
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS- HI. DOT HI
NELSON. NELSON- ALAN ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA. BECKER GORGEOUS.
BRADFORD LATER LATER HI WHAT'S
SO. WHERE SO HI JONES.
CATALOGUER MELENDEZ FORTY NOW.
FORTINO SP SIX TWENTY I'D POURED
INTO YOU KNOW HI RUBIO. RUBIO I
WILL. WELL GUESS THE SIX TWENTY
I'D WILL PROVIDE ME WITH SEVENTY
ONE GERMANY IN EACH ONE. THEY
WERE TO PUT THAT BILL ON CALL-
BUT BEFORE A- THE BILL WILL BE
ON CALL WELL NOW IF THE CALL ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SECTOR CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL OPEN THE ROLE
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR SURE
THIS IS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ABSENT MEMBERS BACKER. WESSEL
CONSENT WHAT IS SO I WILL. WILL
CONSENT CANCELING YOUR HI
WELCOME BY CHAIRMAN THAT'S
FOURTEEN TWO ZERO THAT IS OUT.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA BE IN RECESS
FOR FIVE MINUTES. EXCUSE ME DID. UP BUT THE MEETING- THE CENTRE
ALAN I DIDN'T HEAR YOU SIR. GIVE
OUR CALLING CENTER COMMENTED
OPPORTUNITY TO TEMPT HIM TO ASK
ANOTHER QUESTION ABSOLUTELY
CENTER COME AUGUST FOR JURORS
THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND QUESTION
FOR THE AUTHOR I WAS. WONDERING
IF YOU COULD RESTATE SINCE THIS
IS A POLICY COMMITTEE. WHAT YOU
ARE COMMITTED TO. DOING TO MOVE
THIS BILL FORWARD BECAUSE-
OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW I'M NOT GOOD
AT A LOT OF THINGS BUT I CAN
COUNT. AND IF THIS THING ONLY
HAS SEVEN THEN YOU WON'T BE ABLE
TO DO ANYTHING BECAUSE IT WILL
DIE. AND THEN ALL PARTIES WILL
LOSE SO. IF YOU COULDN'T TELL ME
BY JUST- RESTATING YOUR A
COMMITMENT LEVELS ON THE ISSUES
THAT WERE DISCUSSED IN RAISED IN
THIS POLICY COMMITTEE- THAT MAY
HELP ME. BECAUSE I CERTAINLY.
DON'T THINK YOU CAN MAKE CHANGES
TO MAKE THE BILL BETTER IF THE
BILL IS DEAD. THANK YOU SENATOR
COM MARGARET CENTER ALAN FOR
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR AND
I APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY-
SO. THE FIRST NUMBER ONE WE
COMMIT TO WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH STAKEHOLDERS- YOU'VE
OBVIOUSLY HEARD FROM FOLKS FROM
LABOR FROM THE GROCERY
COMMUNITY. OUT FROM THE
DISTRIBUTOR COMMUNITY WE NEED TO
SIT DOWN AND REALLY WE'VE TALKED
TO THEM BUT WE NEED TO DO A LOT
MORE. DISCUSSION WITH THEM WITH
THE FOLKS ARE ON THE SUPPORT OF
SIDE. NOW I DO THINK THAT IN THE
END OF THE DAY. OUR OUR CORE
GOALS ARE NOT IN CONGRESS. I AND
THEN WHAT IS WHAT'S THE WHAT
SORT OF DEAL WITH THIS LOOK LIKE
I THINK IT'S ULTIMATELY GOING TO
HAVE TO INVOLVE LOWERING THE
NUMBER OF BOTTLES ARE PER
CONSUMER PER MONTH AND I THINK
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
SOME PATH TO- TO REALLY FOCUS
THE BILL AND ON THOSE SMALLER
PRODUCTS THOSE THOSE THOSE
SMALLER VOLUME PRODUCTS THAT
STRUGGLE TO GET OUT INTO THE
BROADER MARKET THAT ARE HARD FOR
THE AVERAGE CONSUMER. TO
PURCHASE DOWN AT THE CORNER
STORE- THAT THAT'S ULTIMATELY
WHAT I'M TRYING TO ADDRESS HERE
WITH THIS BILL. SO I ILL IF
YOU'D BE WILLING SENATOR TO
GIVE. THE CHAIR AND I- AND YOU
KNOW THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE
WORKING ON A ON A DEAL. ALONG
THOSE IN WITH IT WITHOUT WITHOUT
UNDERSTANDING. ALONG THOSE LINES
I WOULD CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT AND WHEN VERY MUCH
WELCOME YOU ARE AND EVERY
MEMBER. OF THIS COMMITTEE'S
ENGAGEMENT. IN HELPING TO SHAPE
ON THE GO SYSTEM MOVING FORWARD. BUT BUT ULTIMATELY IT'S ABOUT
SUPPORTING SMALL BUSINESSES.
FIRST AND FOREMOST IN THE
SMALLER PRODUCTS. I THANK YOU
FOR THAT I AM SO I AM YOU KNOW
IN THAT. HEY I BELIEVE IN KARMA-
N. B. YOU CAN'T DO WHAT YOU SAY
YOU'RE GOING TO DO IF THE THING
DOESN'T MOVE- SO AND I ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT WE- ARE SHORT
SOME MEMBERS SO THAT'S A WHOLE
OTHER CONVERSATION FOR ANOTHER
TIME- AND THAT IF WE  THIS
AGAIN. AND THOSE THINGS HAVEN'T
BEEN ADDRESSED AND THEN WE'LL
PROBABLY BE HAVING A DIFFERENT
SET OF DISCUSSIONS SO THANK YOU
. WELL YOU GOTTA CHANGE YOUR PRO
. THE THIRD REVIEW. WE'RE GONNA
MOVE THE- AND WE'RE GONNA OPEN
THE CALL ONE MORE TIME. WE'RE
GONNA OPEN THE CALL ON- S. B.
SIX TWENTY. SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THIS IS THE F. B. SIX
TWENTY OPEN UP THE ROLE- ABSENT
MEMBERS ARCHULETA. BACKER
GORGEOUS BRADFORD JONES CAN
LONGER CAN LABOUR I'D MELENDEZ.
IT'S EIGHTY ONE SERMON ABILITY
OUT. BILL HAS- EIGHT VOTES AND
ONE NO- THAT BILL IS OUT I
APPRECIATE THE- THE DIALOGUE AND
THE COMMITMENT THAT WAS MADE BY
THE AUTHOR AND I'LL BE THERE
WITH HIM TO SUPPORT HIM AND ALL
OF YOU ON THIS- IMPORTANT POLICY
MATTER. I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATE IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU'RE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AS WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY OF
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD. THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU EVERYONE
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION IS
A JERK.